come in a little closer zoom in zoom in
come on hey i'm going to tell you
something
hey
the moon
yeah it's fake
whoa now that's a shot what am i seeing
why does it keep going move these goofs
no my hat no careful you might get a
critical thought in your brain
okay i'm not gonna lie this kind of
looks fake so why does this look fake
welcome to a surprise round of vfx
artists react to the moon landing yeah
everyone's like saying hey get some nasa
scientists in there to talk about the
moonlight no get some vfx artists in
there
because it's
the effects
all right so we're going to pull up the
apollo 11 documentary where they
basically took all the archival footage
from the moon landing
and
i maxed it
we're gonna watch these shots and we'll
take a look at them as special effects
official effects artists how would we do
these shots or are they even possible
why or why not let's jump in i love our
hats
miniature work dude rear projection
little shots like this you could you
could fake this shot yeah
yeah okay so here's a shot
that's an actual 3d surface down there
you might say well if you built a
miniature so when you're filming stuff
in miniature
there's a very very shallow depth of
field if it's a small object and you're
using a normal sized camera basically
you get extreme depth of field things
become out of focus very quickly and
it's hard to compensate with that the
only way to do that is to stop down to
an extreme level like an f22 and then
blast it with something brighter than
the sun
let's let it see how long the shot goes
on for
this shot is still going whoa
okay
it just got way more impossible
there's no lights in the ceiling
so if you built this whole thing in
miniature and your camera is this big
you're looking like at least a football
field sized
stage this would have to be built
indoors too by the way because it's all
shaded the sky is black there's no blue
spill this is all lit from a single
light source dude space lasers the
ceiling would have to be so high and the
light would have to be so bright to
cover this entire area in an even wash
of light because otherwise you have a
hot spot whichever is closest to the
light well that's the other thing is
that like in order to actually evenly
light a whole bunch of stuff it would
just be too soft you wouldn't have any
sharp shadows like you see on the moon
and when you do get the sharp shadows
they're going to be at angles they're
never going to quite get parallel unless
you literally throw millions of miles
into the mix yeah if you guys like these
videos and you like this channel and you
want to get more consider subscribing to
quarterdigital.com it helps us out helps
you out make better content by doing so
i want to see the actual footage of them
running across the moon because people
are like oh you could just slow down the
footage slow motion that makes
anti-gravity right
now these goofs
these guys are moving in slow motion
that guy sure didn't move that slow
kicked out at regular speed once again
if these guys were on earth look at the
ups that that guy has in that spacesuit
well he could be on wires nico you could
be on wires could he i don't know about
that
that's a big area to put a wire in
somehow and then if these guys are
recorded in slow motion one uh you only
record things in slow motion for like a
minute back in the day oh yeah that's
the other thing
motion cameras if you were to do this
like you could only shoot for like a few
like 30 seconds at a time
it would be impossible
to record slow motion for the length of
time that we see some of these shots run
for i was rolling on the moon one day
okay i'm not gonna lie this kind of
looks fake
so why does this look fake
i'm getting that like hollywood backdrop
look where it's just that clean line
oh but see but that's the thing the
moment he starts running and you realize
no oh oh
that's no backdrop we just zoomed in so
his skill
compared to that back that backdrop was
like hundreds of feet tall at the very
least
also another thing to keep in mind is
that the reason why it does look
slightly uncanny is the fact that you
can see so far and it completely
destroys your sense of scale because
there's no atmospheric dispersion of the
light fog basically yeah there's no fog
there's zero haze in any of these shots
notice that you can see all the way out
to the edge of the horizon and there's
zero haze because there's no air on the
moon so like that distant crater off in
the distance is gonna be just as sharp
as the rock at your feet it's also worth
pointing out the way the dust is blowing
would be impossible if there was air in
that room when you have air and you blow
more air into it you get vertices you
get turbulence
so just like when a rocket takes off you
have a little bit of a streak and it was
poof and it becomes all puffy
there's no puffiness there because
there's no air to create resistance so
you go and the particle just goes
so that shot that we just saw with the
dust would have also been filmed in a
vacuum
if there's one thing there's one thing
that i've learned from shooting cool
sci-fi stuff it's that having reflective
space helmets
is the hardest thing to deal with on set
because you always see the camera and
you always see the lights and you always
see the microphones there are no lights
being reflected there in that helmet you
can actually see neil armstrong holding
the hasselblad camera pointed at buzz
aldrin right there so buzz aldrin may
have not been the first person on the
moon he's the first model on the moon
these videos on the moon are really
crazy to watch if you have any other
real life phenomenon that people think
are real or fake and would love us to
break down like this let us know in the
comments below let's watch them leave
the moon
all right
all right there they are the little
white dot
whoa no way
yeah cool
this could not be stop motion stop
motion be impossible to get that kind of
motion out of it it just would you can't
get that kind of smooth yeah so you got
perspective shifts in the background so
it's not a painting yeah they're moving
around an object that would have to be a
model or something that somebody has
built let's just let it keep going
though all right unbroken shot here we
go
it still hasn't actually left frame and
it started out so tiny you couldn't even
resolve it and now it's like
very noticeable in the shot yeah the
only way to do that shot of the
moonlander coming back to the orbiter
is you'd have to build a giant spherical
art piece and spin it and then you'd
have to have a little thing
move across the disc it's a model i
guess it had be a pretty big model for
the amount of detail on it you'd have to
have an arm a mechanical arm but yeah
you couldn't paint it out there's no
blue screen here there's no blue screen
fringing or edging can we look at a
scene it's 2001 really quick 2001 a
space odyssey directed by stanley
kubrick came out just a year before the
moon landing so it's a great reference
for the best of the best for visual and
special effects at that time
and we can see how it stacks up to the
actual moon landing here
just immediately
it looks so different like you can tell
the planet in the background is just a
static painting and again we're dealing
with deep space stuff where the harsh
shadows are easier to get but the
lighting doesn't match up between the
planet and the space station and there's
bounce light on the space station that's
coming from who knows where
once again there's no perspective shifts
on any of this stuff because the way
they had to do these shots is basically
do a painting they can put little you
know bits of footage like these people
at their stations
but notice the camera doesn't move
anywhere in the scene it's just locked
and it zooms out
hey look at all the turbulence in that
smoke oh yeah dude yeah
so see how it's curling you would not
have any curls on the moon
so this is a funny april fool's idea
we've had for a long time i'm glad we
finally got to sit down and do it yeah
believe it or not i think the technology
required to fake the moon landing to the
extent that we would see it is almost
more ambitious and harder to do
than going to the moon
almost it's significantly harder
thanks for watching everybody
happy april fool's days or if you're
watching this till later time then happy
day whatever day it is
yeah keep thinking critically consider
subscribing i'll see you guys in the
next one